John Miller's NYPD's Deputy Commissioner
of intelligence and counterterrorism he
is also our former senior correspondent
John welcome back good to be back you
have taught us here at this table that
you don't make judgments until you got
as many facts as you possibly can
but knowing what you know did he act
alone did he had help and what drove him
to do it so that's a key question for us
and right now we're kind of going
backwards on the joint terrorism task
force with the FBI through all those
communications those of which we can get
and we can see trying to figure out is
this inspired he just got all this off
the internet was it enabled was he
actually communicating with Isis
officials over encrypted channels or was
it directed was this part of a plan at
this point we don't see anything that
leads us to believe there's anyone else
involved but I caution or a day or two
into this you believe he was self
radicalized it appears from what we know
now and this could change that he was
radicalized after he came to the United
States
I keep thinking John how tough it is
looking at mr. Drake talking about that
he's not angry that he's hurt I keep
thinking how hard it must be for the
victim's families to hear this guy just
bragging about what he's done and
gleeful about what he's done showing no
remorse I want to hear more about that
from the law enforcement part of you
what that means you to hear this guy
bragging about it and what the fact that
he's alive certainly is an advantage
what you hope to learn from him now when
you capture a live terrorist you have
the ability to question that person and
you you're able to glean a lot about
those things were they part of a larger
network is this something bigger were
they acting alone but you can also go
deeper into those questions about what
brought you to this point and there are
former defendants in cases like this
where we've learned a lot about the arc
of their radicalization and what we're
seeing today is in the United States a
great deal of that is just done online
can I ask you President Trump said
yesterday that psy paav potentially
brought 23 people with him when he came
to the United States what do you know
about the president's claim
nothing about that I think he seems to
be referring to other people that came
in that visa program a part of that
program is once you get here you have
the opportunity to bring family members
but no suggestion of there are 23 other
people who know some tell you that
there's a I think that would be a
stretch what did you learn from the note
the note has a lot of potential
significance what the note says is not
terribly informative it says the Islamic
state will endure forever multiple times
on a couple of pieces of paper but the
fact that there was a note left at the
scene in the truck on the ground means
he was following the ISIS instructions
which says if you're gonna do this you
need to claim credit for Isis or we
won't know you're one of us and to yell
it out post it online or their magazine
even suggested leaving leaflets and this
seems to touch on that last piece how
would we break through this arc of
radicalization you talked about Charlie
this is something that it's vexed us
since 9/11 when the US government
started looking at this and it is a
prescription that is very hard for the
government to deliver this is something
that we we have been in discussions with
the larger Muslim community about how to
do and we're not there yet we have no
effective counter message today thank
you John thank you John